quién soy yo
esa es la pregunta que me hice cuando
decidí participar en esta convocatoria
tenía que rellenar un formulario grabar
un vídeo que mandé cuando quedaba solo
un minuto para que acabase el plazo y no
fue porque soy terriblemente
desorganizada que también sino porque me
cuesta mucho definirme sé que soy muchas
cosas y también que pueden cambiar en
pocos minutos estamos acostumbrados a
definirnos por lo que hacemos en la vida
me llamo celia tengo 19 años y estudió
comunicación audiovisual
las respuestas cambian pero el esquema
siempre es el mismo
y esto viene porque desde fuera nos
llega constantemente la idea de que
tenemos que saber quiénes somos
describe t en un minuto en una
entrevista de trabajo
defínete en la biografía de las redes
sociales tienes que saber en todo
momento y con total seguridad quién eres
y cuantas menos palabras mejor
el año pasado hice un curso de igualdad
de género en mi universidad y me di
cuenta de que muchas de las cosas que yo
pensaba que formaban parte de mí me
habían sido impuestas cuando nací repase
mi vida y recordé por ejemplo que en el
colegio mi uniforme siempre consistió en
llevar falda nunca me planteé llevar
pantalones y era un colegio mixto y
llevar falda lo cambia todo cuesta más
condiciona los juegos y la manera de
sentarse
eso me llevó a reflexionar sobre todos
esos elementos que condicionan mi
identidad desde fuera como pertenecer a
un grupo sobre todas esas cosas que
marcan mi identidad esa lucha constante
entre la identidad que elijo para mí y
la que me imponen
fue el día antes de ir a un viaje a
barcelona con mi madre cuando perdí el
dni y me dijo celia como no lo
encuentres no te subes al avión conmigo
yo podía ir perfectamente con mi cuerpo
y voz y mis cejas pero ese trozo de
papel plastificado de 85 x 53 milímetros
de alto me lo iba a impedir al final lo
encontré y luego está perder varias
veces desde entonces pero siempre acaba
pareciendo persiguiéndome con esa foto
sería estática y descolorida que parece
sacada de un archivo carcelario
pero si un dni no nos representa
qué es lo que podría hacerlo esa es la
pregunta que me hice cuando decidí
impartir un taller llamado dime tu
número y te diré quién eres en el que
proponía a las participantes reinventar
su dni a modo de fanzines
para los que no sepáis lo que es un
fanzine es una auto publicación es decir
todo el proceso desde su creación hasta
su producción y distribución lo haces tú
me encantan los fanzines porque ofrecen
todas las posibilidades del mundo formas
colores contenido cada fan thing es
único y diferente como las identidades y
lo bueno de escapar de esa presentación
estándar es que en menos de dos horas lo
que dura el taller salen cosas como
estas
sobres aparentemente normales que al
darles la vuelta vomitan partes de lo
que es
colas de figuras y fotos que solo
entiende la que las une nuestra
identidad es también un corte y pega
hecho de las personas que nos rodean
fotos raspadas perfecto para tapar la
cara de criminales con que nos sacan a
todos o siguiendo con la idea de que las
identidades son cambiantes el dni de
nerea
que como veis es una ruleta
mi dni perfecto es un comecocos porque
tiene caras y dentro de ellas otras más
que se despliegan
dependiendo del número que elige la otra
persona sabe una u otra cosa sobre mí y
si algún día deja de representar me pues
me hago otro con palabras distintas otro
de los asistentes al taller hizo también
un comecocos y aunque nuestra base
material era la misma salieron cosas
completamente diferentes
el dejo la parte de fuera en blanco y la
de dentro la llenó de colores y
purpurina
no debemos intentar definir la identidad
sino definir la identidad a veces puede
ser cuando estoy con una persona que me
hace sentir más yo que nunca o todo lo
que llevo en la cartera o un lugar para
ti puede ser el sueño que tuviste anoche
así que os invito a que participéis en
esta reinvención de vuestra identidad
haciendo vuestro propio dni alternativo
y como celia cómo podemos hacerlo os
estaréis preguntando pues muy fácil como
os dé la gana
nacho por ejemplo empezó a trabajar
sobre la idea de que es lo que ve por
las mañanas cuando se mira en el espejo
e hizo un dni superponiendo varias capas
de autorretratos
lo que hizo el chico de las gafas no
hacer ni caso de lo que les pedí y hacer
un cómic sobre una familia y su perro
ese acto de rebeldía marcó su identidad
muchísimo más de lo que podría haber
hecho cualquier documento y este de aquí
es mi último de neil el definitivo por
ahora
está sujeto al relleno del sujetador así
seguro que nunca más lo pierdo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]